excuse me hi looking for lady's suit
okay what kind a successful business
which flew like Connie Chung or like
dynasty this episode is about a young
woman trying to figure out a way to make
ends meet for her and her son and ends
up opening cookie business by selling in
a very traditional Ugandan marketplace
right you go up there like that it's
gonna make you famous
the character is actually based on a
real story
Elizabeth Kazuto who is a Ugandan woman
who came here and started her own
business selling cookies in Louisville
I'm staying on your hair right now
African imagine
so I'm an immigrant and I came to the
States for college and so I feel like I
brought my own life experiences I know
what it is to be in this country I know
what it is to want to succeed in this
century
[Music]
the talent on this episode is fantastic
I think Kimi and innocent who plays her
son they bring us into authenticity and
playfulness that is really infectious
with a crew at the center
[Music]
the crews amazing from the props to the
Wardrobe everything it just goes through
this filter of are we doing it as
realistically as we can the episode that
were shooting right now the toe polish
wasn't right and the hair and makeup
people caught it and just a B least
heard scruffing the toes right before we
started shooting because that color
nail-polish did not exist in 1981 in
Louisville and if people feel a
connection to Beatrice as a person and
can see her as a full character that
would be ideal somebody who's not a
perfect human being but somebody who has
dreams and obstacles just like the rest
of us it's a beautiful story and a
beautiful TV show that week after week
we'll remind you of all these beautiful
cultures that these people bring into
this country
[Music]
[Applause]
you